what up space fam goals in here from
anime up pro
and i'm here today to discuss the latest
crazy chapter of the attack on titan
story we got some crazy moments in this
one and we're clearly fast approaching
the end here
so make sure to stay tuned for that if
you do enjoy seeing these monthly attack
on titan reviews and want to keep them
coming then the best thing you can do is
smash that like button and share this
video
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
titan videos and you definitely don't
want that because we are fast
approaching the final
intense chapters here so if you have it
make this the day you subscribe and
while you wait for the next insane
chapter to drop
feel free to check out our growing
attack on titan playlist where we got
videos about all of the titan shifters
and their powers
all the acronyms and their powers the
titans ranked from weakest to strongest
and much more link to that is in the
description now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all this
chapter is called the depths of despair
and that's an apt title because this is
definitely not a feel-good chapter
although obviously
most attack on time chapters aren't feel
good chapters we start with historia who
is
finally in the process of giving birth
as all this crazy stuff
is happening in the world and the entire
world is focused on here in the manga
it's like the apocalypse the end of the
world
and we see countless people from
different places and cultures
all awaiting their doom some people run
while others simply pray
even as the colossal titans approach
them and step on them ending their lives
this is harsh and brutal we see the wall
tighten sending a countless amount of
people falling off a cliff
as they all try to run away until they
reach this dead end you can't even
verbalize how insane it is
that so many people are dying more than
you can ever hope to count and it's the
result of our protagonist's actions
of all things we see one especially
heartbreaking moment where a mother
passes her baby overhead
as she reaches the edge of the cliff and
falls to her doom
the baby is passed from person to person
everyone hoping to keep it alive for as
long as possible but the giant colossal
titans tower
over the small baby and it's pretty
clear that the baby as innocent a being
as you can ever find
isn't going to make it at least not if
things continue like this
the size differences go to show how
powerless these humans truly are
in their present situation meanwhile we
jumped their continental aldians the
families of the marlene warriors who are
themselves trying to escape the
approaching titans
we see annie's father and reiner's
mother and so on they look on as
aircrafts approach the titans that are
within view now and these aircrafts as
we're told
are responsible for the fate of humanity
for a while the role of technology has
been emphasized in how technology was
fast improving and would eventually
surpass the power of the titans so
here's the final stand between
technology and the ultimate titan
and we'll see in this chapter who's
stronger and it's crazy to think about
how far we've come from the beginning
where aaron wanted to destroy all titans
and save humanity from them or what he
understood to be humanity
and now aaron is being framed as the
ultimate titan threat to humanity aaron
has definitely become
the very thing he swore to destroy then
we're told that this
is humanity's last fort so most of the
world has already been trampled
countless are dead and now the adults
seem to realize that this is their
responsibility
they point out how they used hate raised
hate
and believed hate to be their savior and
this is very well said here it's said
that they left
all the problems they created on the
island of devils
and as a result that devil was born
meaning aaron to return the hate
they gave it and i'm glad that's been
acknowledged aaron has
undoubtedly crossed the line by killing
so many people including innocent people
why did he do that though because he
felt like it was the only way to save
the island of paradise
and his loved ones there were many that
he couldn't save he already lost his mom
dad and many more and he decided that
even if he needs to become the devil
himself even if he needs to become the
most irredeemable person
in the world he'll do it in order to
best ensure the safety of paradise
and its remaining inhabitants and after
he's gone so far
it's hard to believe that he'd stop now
the world hated the island want to
exterminate it
and so they can't be surprised that
someone from the island
would return that hate and want to
exterminate them and it's key here where
he says
us adults because they're the ones who
should have known better but
because they didn't even the innocent
children are suffering and the man says
that if given another chance he swears
not to make the same mistakes
this sort of reminds me of pain from
naruto and his philosophy
he planned for people to experience so
much suffering that they'd never want to
experience it again
and that would lead to lasting peace you
could say that aaron just caused this
amount of pain
and suffering but i also fear that
eventually people would forget and
repeat the mistakes of the past
there's no way to predict what would
happen if aaron actually stopped now
and after all this i don't think aaron
wants to take any chances
in the meantime reiner's mother has
flashbacks about her child and breaks
down because she didn't treat reiner
as a child but as a tool of revenge and
annie's father needs to acknowledge that
it was the same with him
we've seen this with the way grisha
treated zeke too they were willing to
sacrifice the lives of their children
if it meant that their children could
become the warriors of marley
and fulfill their parents desires and i
get why they feel horrible
imagine not only putting that much
pressure on your child but also making
it so that in a best case scenario they
would only live
13 years after inheriting the titan
powers because of yamir's curse
and chances are they would die much
sooner in battle
you could call it karma or what goes
around comes around or whatever you want
but you see this recurrently happening
in attack on titan aldians persecuted
the
then the marlins persecuted the eldians
when they got the chance
then the world turned against the island
of paradise and the island specifically
aaron turned against the world aaron
seems to want to take the responsibility
on himself
destroy everyone who might want to
eventually get revenge again
or destroy paradise and then he doesn't
care what happens to him he's okay with
taking on the burden and paying the
price himself
thus allowing his remaining friends to
live in peace the military personnel
talking is clearly not
confident that they'll succeed in taking
down aaron
nevertheless he says he hopes to end
this arab hate
this ships are information they will
start the attack and with that
they hope to start an era of peace and
part ways with their monsters however
parting with the monsters you created
is not that easy and we see that
technology although fast improving
is still not on aaron's ultimate titan
level not even close really they drop
the bombs but the explosions aren't even
big enough to take out a colossal
titan's head
beyond that their accuracy is low and
they also have no idea where aaron's
real body
is then in a warhammer titan-like way
aaron causes the beast titan to manifest
and he uses his throwing abilities to
destroy those blimps
real quick aaron will not be stopped by
technology
it will have to come down to an
old-fashioned titans vs titan's battle
and of course the ackermans too and you
see the little bit of hope
that they had leave the people's eyes as
the airships fall
out of the air all destroyed again we
see innocent children
including a baby crying as they await
the approaching titans
finally forced to accept the end annie's
father mentions that at least annie and
reiner are alive on paradise island
and won't die before their parents at
death's door
they finally become more parent-like
prioritizing their children ahead of
themselves
and their desires and reiner's mother
takes comfort
in the thought as well and says that's
enough for her
without tears they both bravely await
the end
and this often seems to be the case when
faced with death
humans and their true priorities become
clear but then just when they think
they're on the brink of death
the plane approaches with levi armin
mikasa and everyone else
as if things weren't crazy enough the
engine is almost dead
so they're gonna get as close as
possible to the founding titan
and then onyankopon is gonna do a crash
landing whether he'd survive that at
this point
is questionable but even the planned
crash landing gets complicated by the
beast titan hitting the plane
and levi's pissed as ever to see this
monkey tighten again and as we know
the beast titan is their target because
they believe that if they could separate
the beast titan and zeke from aaron
he might lose the rumbling power whether
this will work at this point we can't be
sure but they're gonna try and it's
interesting that aaron could stop these
guys whenever he wanted to with his
founding titan powers but he wants them
his close friends to remain free to
choose their own paths
even if that means them killing him and
as we know armin could use the colossal
titan explosion ability to wipe out
aaron but he
too only wants to use that as a last
resort the forces jump out to meet aaron
and the beast titan and reiner's armored
titan is the first one to engage the
beast titan
historically the beast titan mop the
floor with the armored titan but
reiner's got back up and zeke is most
likely not in control of the beast titan
right now
which is most likely obeying aaron's
will it is a crazy moment to see
reiner's
mother as she looks on at her son
transforming in an attempt to save her
and the rest of humanity this is
something attack on titan did really
well
showing us two different and opposing
sides in great detail
reiner is arguably the second
protagonist of attack on titan in a
sense
and aaron's character foil and seeing
him now take on a hero like position
trying to save his people after being
the one to attack aaron's people
is quite the narrative turn and the
people at humanity's last
base noticed the odm gears and realized
that those are paradise forces
working with the armored titan and card
titan in order to try to save them armin
wants to ask aaron one last time what
part of him is free
after they rip him out of his ultimate
titan in the words
fight until the bitter end are written
on the last page
as the final fight is in full swing and
this time the armored titan is the one
who
right now at least has the upper hand
against the beast titan
absolutely insane stuff almost all of
the titan shifters are here
and after everything that's happened i
feel like we can expect to see
falco's newly flying titan show up next
chapter
carrying annie after all annie's father
has been pretty heavily highlighted here
and he's been integral to annie's story
so you know she's gonna make an
appearance and then all the titan
shifters
would be present for the final epic
fight armin's question was very
interesting when he asked aaron
what part of you is free because he does
seem to be a kind of
slave at this point to carrying out his
final plan to eradicate the world
trying to move forward with it no matter
what it takes
in my view aaron is choosing to be the
devil in a lelouch from code geass kind
of way
except way more extreme he wants to take
all that hate that was mentioned and
focus it on himself
it's his free choice to take on that
role and he's left his friends free to
stop him
and when they stop him how could the
rest of humanity hate the island
dwellers
anymore after they saved them from the
devil himself
so i feel like aaron being wiped out by
his friends as gene suggested
is part of his plan but whether it will
go down like that remains to be seen
and that is it for this insane chapter
of attack on titan i mean they're all
pretty insane and this is one of the
best manga ever but this one
was especially crazy with the final
fight officially underway
let me know your thoughts on aaron's
plan what you thought about this chapter
and what you expect to see happening
next do you agree that we're gonna need
to see a flying falco and annie show up
soon i must say i absolutely love how
the flying falco titan idea popped up
again
because i remember how everyone was
guessing that falco would be the 9th in
flying titan
when he was introduced and he reached
out for a bird overhead on a battlefield
and although the 9th titan turned out to
be the warhammer titan it's still
really cool how those flying titan
theories about falco
seem like they're actually going to come
into fruition but anyways if you did
enjoy this review and want to keep the
attack on time videos coming the best
thing you can do is warhammer smash that
like button and share this video
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future attack on titan videos and you
definitely don't want that
since we are clearly in the final and
most intense chapters right now so if
you haven't make this the day you
subscribe
and while you wait for the next attack
on titan chapter to drop
feel free to check out our colossal
attack on time playlist where we got
videos about the titan shifters all
ackermanns the titans ranked from
weakest to strongest
and much more link to that is in the
description and i especially want to
thank the patron squad over on patreon
and here on youtube who helped make
videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord twigo himself
alpha sigma and are the one tier patrons
the ones who stand atop
all clans in grata the world acquire
respect
liam thompson pate heffa red-haired
raven
emperor otaku thomas jones spidey life
tinnell
and baked buddhist and our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only gilgamesh who's
the current most donated overall
champion of the world
steelers angel cruz anatoly kazowski
cricket xp
joel stanton rethurine de ora very gucci
jessica kayla fond alicia actor hinokami
and water bonnie parks
florian joanne garcia jack watches anime
deadly saint high school dxd73 matthew
cruz and anthony schreiber thank you all
so much if you do enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patreon
today for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here
and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully
already destroyed so yeah you can
support more content that way if you
prefer
whichever way to support us you can get
the same great
benefits and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you